messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors jean
didier berthault ans le projet de loi
instaurant le pass vaccinale était
devant l'assemblée nationale il ya
quelques jours et on peut dire que la
droite était plutôt divisée sur la
question
serait question du pass festival la
position de la candidate en tout cas
valérie pécresse a été a été très clair
et nous avons toujours dit que c'était
un des éléments qui étaient nécessaires
à ce dispositif sanitaire pour lutter
contre la pandémie pourquoi il ya eu
confusion pourquoi il ya eu confusion il
ya eu confusion parce que les propos que
vous avez souligné du président de la
république ont été en était scandaleux
et qu'on a ajouté une crise politique à
une crise sanitaire donc on commence
l'année 2022 comme nous avons terminé
l'année 2000 21 en divisant les français
en les montant les uns contre les autres
et c'est absolument l'effet inverse
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait avoir pour
pour mener pour me des aviales la lutte
contre contre cette épidémie je crois
que nous sommes à la veille d'une
élection présidentielle qui est d'une
extrême importance
les français ont besoin et d'un
véritable d'un véritable débat et pas de
polémique comme celle ci surtout sur la
santé des uns contre les autres il
s'agit pas de stigmatiser une partie des
citoyens il s'agit de mettre à
disposition un outil qui est un outil
indispensable mais qui n'est pas le seul
pour lutter contre produite est contre
cette pandémie et je crois que ses
propos maladroits n'ont fait
qu'envenimer les choses ils sont
regrettables et on voit aujourd'hui que
on continue à mettre une partie des
français dans la rue c'est certainement
pas l'objectif qu'il faut pour aborder
cette future campagne présidentielle
jean didier berthault en vous parlez de
confusion les une position qui était
peut-être un peu fou quelle est la
position de valérie pécresse sur ce pass
vaccinale c'est une position claire a
comparé à certains députés de la droite
on sait qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
pour se passe vaccinale valérie pécresse
est elle en faveur de ce pass oui
valérie pécresse est en faveur de ses
passes mais l'immense majorité des
députés les républicains ont soit voter
pour soit se sont abstenus en tout cas
dans leur très grande majorité ne se
sont pas opposés à ce passe d' accident
ce qui a créé la confusion à l'assemblée
nationale ce sont les propos du
président de la république et c'est lui
seul qui aujourd'hui pour que la
responsabilité de ce qui est en train de
se passer williams martinien votre avis
est clair sur le pass vaccinale pas
sanitaires à bientôt transformée en
passe vaccinale pour vous c'est clair
c'est un objet de discrimination tout à
fait et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
dire que dans quelques jours nous allons
profiter d'une niche parlementaire de la
france insoumise pour faire une
proposition de loi de sortie des régimes
d'exception et notamment d'abrogation l2
se passe sanitaire devenu passe
vaccinale donc effectivement nous nous y
sommes fermement opposés et je crois que
les propos du président de la république
alors évidemment il
il en veut nîmes les choses mais plus
que ça c'est une forme d'aveu puisque
quand emmanuel macron nous dit que
l'objectif du pass annie terre c'est
donc d'emmerder les non vaccinés il
avoue qu' il n'y a pas d'objectif à
proprement parler de santé publique de
dire que dans les lieux collectifs comme
les bars les restaurants les théâtres il
y a une problématique sanitaire
particulière qui justifierait qu'il faut
absolument y être vaccinés en fait
emmanuel macron nous explique que tout
ça mais pas une mesure sanitaire tout ça
est une mesure de sanction de
marginalisation sociale pour les
personnes qui sont non vaccinés et ça je
crois que c'est extrêmement grave que
c'est bon déjà évidemment inefficace du
point de vue sanitaire mais que c'est
effectivement discriminatoire puisqu'il
ya deux catégories de citoyens qui sont
créés avec des droits qui sont inégaux
et on voit bien là la fuite en avant qui
est celle du gouvernement face à cette
crise sanitaire puisqu'il ne prend pas
les bonnes mesures dont on pourra
discuter j'espère sur les créations de
lits d'hospitalisation sur les mises à
disposition de masques ffp2 par exemple
puisqu'il ne prend pas les bonnes
mesures il est dans une fuite en avant
autoritaire discriminatoire et moi je
suis en entendant le conseiller et leur
parlais tout à l'heure je suis vraiment
attristé de voir que il ya une partie de
l'opposition qui malheureusement prend
la roue la d'emmanuel macron et continue
dans cette direction là je crois qu'il
faut être ferme quand ils les libertés
publiques sont menacées de cette façon
il faut être capable de dire non j'en ai
dit
berthod ans j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question qui revient souvent à
quoi sert le pass vaccinale c'est le
vaccin n'empêche pas la contamination
mais comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga le pass
vaccinale c'est un des outils qui est
mis à la disposition pour lutter contre
cette pandémie je viens d'entendre ce
que dit l'orateur de la france insoumise
et malheureusement c'est tout l'erreur
du président de la république c'est que
en insultant eu une partie des français
qui je le répète ne font rien d'illégal
puisque pour l'instant la vaccination
n'est pas obligatoire il a donné
l'opportunité à certains qui sème la
confusion et le doute dans l'esprit des
français c'est le cas de la france a
soumise depuis les débuts de cette
pandémie de s'engouffrer dans cette
brèche et de politiser une gestion de la
lutte contre la pandémie aujourd'hui il
devrait avoir une union nationale sur
pour sortir le plus vite possible de
cette de cette pandémie et de ses
contraintes qui restreignent les
libertés de l'ensemble des français
voilà donc aujourd'hui c'est absolument
la priorité et c'est de ce que nous
avons ce que nous avons choisi par par
l'adoption et par le speaker de ce pass
sanitaires tout d'abord puis ensuite de
ce pass vaccinale c'est de mettre en
place l'ensemble des outils qui peuvent
être nécessaires à la lutte contre cette
pandémie mais en aucun cas de diviser
les français les uns contre les autres
voilà et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui en
stigmatisant une partie des français les
uns contre les autres qu'est ce qu'on
fait on politise et on permet à une
certaine opposition et aux extrêmes que
ce soit à droite ou à gauche de faire
leur lit politique à la veille de ces
élections importantes et pendant ce
temps on ne parle pas d'autre chose non
je crois que c'est tout à fait
regrettable une fois tu sais ce que je
dis c'est le président de la république
qui porte le seul aujourd'hui la
responsabilité de ses divisions
effectivement on n'a pas non seulement
employé des termes comme ceux ci mais on
n'a pas en r d une partie des français
qui ne sont pas dans l'illégalité moi je
préférais que président de la république
il emmerde les délinquants ils emmerdent
les clandestins peut-être un petit peu
plus que des français qui peut être pour
beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs n'ont
pas encore eu l'opportunité en raison
des déserts médicaux en raison d'un
certain nombre de désorganisation des
services de santé aujourd'hui en france
voir se faire avec
william martin va plus parler de
politique mais on va parler de crise
sanitaire a réellement avec des
indicateurs en berne un nouveau variant
omikron avec une vague qui déferle
plutôt fort sur le pays si la
vaccination est une bonne chose et qu'on
doit pas imposer le pass vaccinale il
faudrait donc inciter les gens la
vaccination différemment avec de la
conviction et non de la contrainte
comment on fait justement
alors déjà on identifie bien le public
cible on a eu la ces derniers jours
quelques enquêtes qui était très
intéressante pour comprendre qui était à
la fois les personnes non vaccinées les
raisons pour lesquelles elle ne se
vaccinent est pas et parmi ces personnes
qui étaient celles qui étaient les plus
à risque on voit bien aujourd'hui que
par exemple dans les admissions dans les
services de réanimation
les personnes qui sont frappés par le
cos vide et qui malheureusement risque
d'en mourir sont des personnes qui sont
relativement âgés à la moyenne d'âge
d'admission en réanimation est de 79 ans
est généralement avec des cobras des
comorbidités donc là l'enjeu en termes
de politique de vaccination ça doit être
absolument la priorité des priorités
c'est d'aller voir ces personnes âgées
avec des comorbidités qui sont éloignés
du système de santé qui ne sont
peut-être pas au courant de comment
fonctionne la politique vaccinale qui
sont très sûrement isolées socialement
en général la priorité des priorités
c'est d'aller voir ces personnes là pour
leur proposer la vaccination puisque
dans ce cadre là on va pouvoir vraiment
les protéger on va pouvoir vraiment
sauver des vies à partir du moment où on
arrive à bien cibler le public pour qui
la vaccination est la plus utile et la
plus intéressante donc ça c'est le
l'aspect l'urgence pour ce qui est de la
politique de vaccination et de la
protection des personnes mais il ya
aussi tout un autre champ de mesures
qu'on pourrait appeler des mesures
préventives celles qui doivent empêcher
la circulation du virus au sein de la
société qui sont extrêmement importantes
là on a depuis la semaine dernière
depuis cette semaine la rentrée scolaire
et on voit bien à quel point avec un
protocole qui d'un protocole sanitaire
qui était sorti dans un journal payant
la veille de la rentrée scolaire
on voit bien le niveau d'impréparation
du gouvernement là il y a urgence dans
les écoles à généraliser les
purificateurs d'air les détecteurs de
co2 à mettre à disposition de tous les
personnels de l'éducation nationale des
masques ffp2 puisqu'on sait que c'est
cela qui sont les plus efficaces pour
éviter la transmission du virus bref il
ya des mesures dont maintenant toutes
les études tous les scientifiques
s'accordent à dire que ce sont des
mesures qui sont efficaces qui permet de
très de prévenir la circulation du virus
et donc il faut le faire et quand le
gouvernement le fait pas mais c'est lui
finalement qui rentrent dans la
catégorie des irresponsables là je
reprends les mots que emmanuel macron à
utiliser dans son interview pour
désigner les non vaccinés moi je pense
que les irresponsables c'est par exemple
le ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
suffisamment de purificateurs d'air de
détecteurs de co2 et de masques ffp2
dans l'éducation nationale jean didier
berthault williams martinez merci à vous
messieurs d'avoir été avec nous williams
martinez et orateur de la france
insoumise et jean didier berthault un
conseiller l air de paris merci à vous
de monsieur